welcome to our first speaker
yes thank you very much
I'm Richard King you were probably
expecting Fernando brandão but he
couldn't make it and so instead I'm
replacing him but I'm talking about a
joint project that we did together at
Caltech so Fernando myself and Daniel
Stout franca who is in Copenhagen and
this is a very complicated title but we
were all very excited by the recent
developments regarding quantum speedups
for optimization problems that were
arguably started by Fernando brandão and
Krista's war in 2017 and this was all
very surprising to us but unfortunately
the entire approach depends on problems
specific parameters and these parameters
explode for some of the most important
application of seven semi-definite
programming so there was a gaping hole
in the theory and we try to fill that
and sdp approximations for binary
quadratic optimization exactly kind of
the kind of problems that the original
approaches couldn't address and I will
try to point out why and I will try to
give a rather conceptual talk about how
we managed to overcome this ok so here's
a brief outline of my talk I want to
give a big quick motivation
very broadly and then focus on the
problem we want to consider SDP
relaxations of binary quadratic problems
and then I want to actually take some
time to develop a quantum inspired meta
algorithm it's actually very similar to
Mira descent for those of you who know
that is able to address the specific
structure associated with these kinds of
problems that made it hard to tackle
with the existing SDP so verse and then
I will do a quick runtime analysis
because this Mater algorithm can be
implemented either on a fully classical
device but if we had access to a quantum
computer or new ideas on how to simulate
quantum computers efficiently this can
be further boosted and at least on paper
the results that will show regarding
runtime are actually competitive and
then I want to do a quick summary and
close this so let's start with the
motivation has already set
I'm very a plant that's very exciting
but quantum algorithms for optimization
tasks is a very promising rather new
idea would say and with a broad scope of
possible applications and today I want
to make mainly focus on speed ups for
semi definite or convex optimization
problems and that we know that all the
also classical solvers are efficient in
theory convex optimization problems are
not difficult from a CCS two point of
view but the problem is if you actually
want to run them they get slow very very
quickly and storage is a problem so what
we are hunting for here are not these
amazing exponential speed ups that some
quantum algorithms promise but more
milder speed ups but for arguably a very
broad and useful class of problems so
kind of the stakes a bit lower in this
talk we want to do polynomial speed ups
only but at least have like a broad
range of applicability okay so that's
the main idea and an important example
as I pointed out what I want to focus on
is semi definite programming but one of
the tricks that we will use is we will
actually don't use the semi definite
programming structure but embedded in a
more general convex optimization problem
and as I also already said existing
quantum algorithms at least the one by
brandão and swar who were raised later
improved by and Raj and his gang from
from the Netherlands kind of don't
always yield improvements at least don't
always yield improvements so kind of the
dependent problem specific parameters
and you have to check that first and it
can happen and in fact sometimes it
happens that you don't see a speed-up
and so we want to focus on this and the
most important open challenge wash that
that was really vexing relaxations of
binary quadratic problems they are very
very popular in the computer science
literature some important advances like
matrix multiplicative weights were
developed specifically to address these
problems and this is arguably a
battlefield where like the classical
competition is particularly strong and
so we wanted to address that and we
found some some mild improvements but
again I want to emphasize it's rather
mild compared to other branches and our
ideas to tackle this problem and to
overcome shortcomings of existing SDP
solvers is the first thing we have to do
and I will emphasize that later is we
have to bundle many a linear many linear
constraints together so typically you
phrase an SDP as a problem with linear
constraints a linear objective function
and the PSD constraint but nothing in
principle stops you from bundling
several linear constraints together and
feud as a more general convex
optimization problem and we will have to
do that to overcome the shortcomings
shortcomings and the second important
ideas that we developed a primal only
classical algorithm so the original
quantum SDP servers were motivated by
matrix multiplicative weight algorithms
developer Aurora and kale and they kind
of jump back and forth from primal and
dual solutions in order to arrive at an
optimum and this kind of introduces a
dependence on the size of the problem
and this can actually be overcome by
just looking at a primal only solution
and this is very similar to mirror isn't
and finally as it I think now a mainstay
is we kind of embed quantum coelom
simulation like deep sampling as a fast
subroutine that could in principle
speed-up the classical procedure further
so we are building a pretty fast
classical algorithm that has a
bottleneck mainly computing matrix
Exponential's and then we are going to
use potential quantum devices to speed
up the subroutine of computing matrix
Exponential's so that's the high-level
idea that allowed us to attract address
these kind of problem classes with the
original ideas by Fernando bundle and
Christus 4 ok it's about time to
introduce the problem I think and binary
quadratic optimization problems of the
following form we have an N dimensional
vector
but with binary constraints so it can
only be plus or minus 1 and then we want
to optimize they maximize a quadratic
function in these binary vectors it's a
very general problem it appears there's
a lot of applications and it's very
nasty it looks like there's integer
constraints and a naive approach would
require exponentially many test cases to
find the optimal solution important
examples include and that should already
scare you max cut and cut norm
important graph theoretical problems
in data analysis community detection can
often be phrased in this way and
something that is very near and dear to
me turns out that if you're interested
in rigorous structured matrix
factorizations then these can often be
formulated as problems of this form and
so they also appear there and if you are
a true Finnish physicist by heart and
just think about easing models and spin
glasses similar problems
classical easing models so this is a
binary quadratic optimization problem
and it should shock nobody that this is
hard in general and so an obvious way to
take the hard problems is to relax it to
something that is easy at least in
theory and that's what the SDP
relaxation does so let me rewrite this
problem again I kind of reformulate it a
bit because I can consider each X I can
rewrite the Quranic function as a linear
function in the outer product and the
outer product is always positive
semi-definite I can replace it by a
matrix X and because the original vector
is diagonal you can quickly check that
this order product only has plus ones on
the diagonal and so equivalently by
replacing this X X adjoint by matrix X
this problem is equivalent to the
following problem where I also have to
introduce an additional rain constraint
because here I'm only optimizing over
outer product and the SDP relaxation is
pretty simple it just says this is a
nice constraint is another constraint is
this SDP constraint this is very nasty
let's not just not do that just erase it
and then you arrive at an SDP relaxation
of the problem and this is the problem
class of semi definite programs that we
want to address today and this convex
relaxation is kind of nice the objective
function is linear and the constraint
set is an intersection of two convex
sets where one of them is a convex cone
just the cone of positive semi-definite
matrices and the other one is the set of
all matrices whose diagonal entries are
nailed down to be ones and there's two
ways of viewing that you can either view
that as an affine constraint it's a
collection of linear constraints as a
single f-fine constraint or if you
actually want to go to
traditional STP formulations you would
divide that up into n different linear
constraints where each of the
constraints would tell you the first
diagonal entry has to be one second I
acknowledge there has to be one third
diagonal entry has to be one and this
turns out to actually be the problem for
the existing solutions because this
constraint immediately tells you that
every feasible matrix here has to have a
very large trace depends on the
dimension and if you do primal-dual
approaches then they usually depend on
the size of the problem and the size of
the have an additional depends on the
size of the problem and this is very
large here and so if you just take the
existing results by pronounced war for
instance they depend a parameter that is
kind of related to this and it is an
extra dependence that is very a very
large polynomial and so if you insert
that all your speedups are gone like
your runtime immediately becomes much
much worse than a standard interior
point method and so somehow we have to
overcome this problem that the size of
these particular comment or optimization
relaxations is unusually large for
standard matrix multiplicative way to
produce
okay so here's written again the
fundamental problem of this task of this
talk SDP realization of binary quadratic
optimization linear optimization
function these diagonal constraints F an
constraints and I've also included it's
not necessary but if every diagonal
entry has to be one the trace has to be
n and the matrix has to be positive
semi-definite now I want to get this a
bit closer to quantum mechanics world
and so I rescale the problem by kind of
enforcing each of the diagonal I just
rescale the problem such that each of
the diagonal entries has to be 1 over
the dimension and this has an effect on
the trace namely the trace is 1 and now
this second constraint that I call back
calligraphic s is just a constraint that
we are actually optimizing over density
operators over density matrices and then
we optimizing a linear function subject
to an f-fine constraint that I call c1
so far not much interesting has happened
ivory skeletal problem I have to keep
track of that because when we look at
approximations I have to remember but
so far not a big deal I just want to DX
to look more like a quantum state to use
quantum intuition and well this is the
problem want to tackle let me try to
introduce our meat algorithm for that
and it's kind of a free phase
optimization algorithm and the phase one
is very similar to matrix multiplicative
weight and what are Orin Kerr did we
start with an optimization problem but
binary search allows you to reduce this
optimization problem to a sequence of
feasibility problems and that turns out
to help so we kind of start with the
optimization problem replace it by a
sequence of feasibility problems and
then we are left with solving
feasibility problems and for that we
develop a quantum inspired metre
algorithm it's very similar to mirror
descent for those of you know and then
in Phase three there's like a potential
quantum boost or like let's be mourners
call it a smart idea boost there's one
portal neck in this meta algorithm and
money can make progress there then the
runtime improves considerably quantum
computers are one possibility for that
and the inspiration is again matrix
multiplicative weights but we never
considered a dual so it's actually more
similar to a mirror descent approach and
just very quickly this is a standard
trick in optimization Theory the
objective function in our problem is a
linear function and it is also bounded
so the values are always in a unit
interval between minus 1 and 1 and so
you can instead of optimizing your
objective function directly you can
choose a parameter and a possible range
and ask is there a feasible solution to
my problem that kind of whose function
objective value is smaller equal and
lambda so kind of I replace an
optimization with the sequence of
questions and if I'm able to answer this
question I can just scan through the
interval of all possible solutions and
effectively nail down the objective the
optimal value so binary search allows me
to do that and the overhead is very mild
if I'm interested in epsilon accuracy
and because when a unit interval because
a rescaled we only need
to answer until they're always so like
ignoring your birth make factors we only
need to answer a couple of order 1
questions about the feasibility of a
potential solution this is a standard
trick but it's actually important
because for us in this framework solving
feasibility problems is easier than
optimization and now we have a
feasibility problem so we have an
additional parameter lambda that's the
question that's an Optima that's a an
objective a feasible point exists whose
objective function is smaller equal than
lambda so we get a new constraint and
these are just the original
feasibility constraints diagonal has to
be equal to 1 we scaled and we're
optimizing over density matrices so this
is the problem we actually want to
address with our meter algorithm and we
just have to find a matrix and the
matrix has to be in the intersection of
three nice convex sets the new
constraint is a half space just a linear
function has to be smaller than a
certain value the second constraint is
an affine subspace of all matrices whose
diagonal is one whose diagonal entries
are constant and the shirt the third
constraint it's the most interesting one
is that the matrix also has to be
identity operator
exactly I agree I agree this is a
superfluous constraint I agree it's kind
of it's going to be important if you
want to relax the constraints a bit
because maybe you want to have trace
exactly equal to one while you might be
happy with some small inaccuracies there
but you're right in theory I just wrote
one constrain twice very good okay I
call this a quantum inspired change of
variables but it's really just the
mirrored eccentric in this guy's this is
a nice constraint this is another
constraint this constraint is a bit
scary and when I was a chemistry
undergrads the only trick I ever learned
to deal with scary problems is to do a
change of variables that get rid of it
and kind of we also did that here we can
write every positive semi-definite
matrix as a matrix exponential and
matrix Exponential's are automatically
positive semi-definite and if I wanted
to want to nail down the trace
constraint as well I have to divide by
the trace so kind of this is a seems
like a heck but it is least kind of like
a quantum inspired yes change of
variables that makes the last constraint
trivial it will induce new difficulties
but at least I don't have to write down
the PhD constraint explicity and exactly
this change of variables ensures that my
matrix is automatically positive
semi-definite but we have to now reason
about nonlinear functions in the new
mate in a new variable namely the
Hamiltonian or the matrix exponential H
and so we have to find a Hamiltonian a
matrix exponential subject he associate
matrix exponential obeys the linear
constraint and the diagonal constraint
okay and Hamiltonian updates the meet
algorithm just writes down an iterative
heuristics that kind of does that that
tries to find a matrix exponential a
Hamiltonian an energy function
associated with a keep state that obeys
these two feasibility constraints and
the algorithm is really simple
which is start with the zero matrix or
in physics languages with infinite
temperature as a starting point and then
we compute the matrix exponential and we
check if it meets these two constraints
we're looking for feasibility problems
so if it does we're done we found a
feasible solution and if the constraints
are violated we kind of update the
exponent in order to penalize the
directions where it went wrong so kind
of if it if it violated the second
constraint we somehow do something to
the matrix exponential add something
that shrinks the corresponding
directions and because it's a X minus
something we are just adding something
and X minus something becomes smaller so
that's the heuristics idea here's maybe
a couple of pictures to illustrate that
here in this circle this denotes the set
of all positive semi definite matrices
or a change of variables to care of that
and suppose we had a current iteration
row and we are looking for a point in
that intersection of an kind of a non
trivial convex set part of a diamond
here and a half space and what the
algorithm proposes is because all the
sets are convex this this point is in
one of the convex sets but not the other
one and so there exists a separating
hyperplane that separates the two and
then I just add that in the exponent and
you ristic Li that should push me in
this direction and then I just keep
going still not there
find another separating hyperplane
pushes me down there and they should
converge and of course it does that's
the magic of mirror descent
yes
no because kind of like the only we
don't have non kind of like very good
kind of we don't do that we don't do the
projection step we just care that we are
always in the space of positive
semi-definite matrices and we
automatically with this construction and
kind of the way we solve this problem is
that we will relax the problem and we'll
be happy with finding approximately
feasible solutions and then you don't
have to project yes I'm going to say
that very good exactly mirror descent
magic this heuristics actually works and
the number of steps it needs is only
logarithmic in the number of dimension
this is why this approach is powerful at
least in theory and the proof is
actually quantum inspired also the
original proof and it's very important
that we started with the infinite
temperature stage that our first
iteration was zero because then the
Associated starting state is the
maximally mixed state and we can try to
quantify distance in relative entropy
that's the brakeman divergence and we
know that this starting state is special
because if a feasible point exists then
the relative entropy distance is at most
log M just a fundamental feature of
relative entropy as a distance measure
and then the way how you prove this
result is to make sure that in each
iteration where we penalize in feasible
directions we get closer in relative
entropy and this is something you can do
using quantum tricks and now we have a
certain budget and then we either have
to converge after T steps like this
tells us how many but our bigger budget
is all we book gets a relation that
implies that the relative entropy is
negative and we know that this can never
happen and this is actually a very
straight forward half a page proof that
this procedure actually works
after only logarithmically many steps
and the log n comes from this powerful
relation of the form of the relative
entropy and to answer your question the
potential function is different normal
entropy they associate a brakeman
divergence is the relative entropy and
this is what we use
okay so hamiltonian updates this meta
algorithm solves the feasibility problem
in only log and many steps but the
individual steps can be expensive
there's three of them we first have to
compute a matrix exponential and then we
have to check the relatively simple
convex constraints one of them is a
linear constraint and the other one is
checking the diagonal and if any of them
is violated we have to support a
hyperplane a separating hyperplane but
this turns out to be easy your experts
usually ask which one is the expensive
one but it's of course matrix
exponentiation this is the bottleneck
and if you like just do a naive runtime
analysis you get a naive total cost that
scales like the fourth power in the
dimension times the sparsity and this is
really not that impressive
however the proof here turns out to be
surprisingly robust you can like kind of
carry out the same argument even if you
don't implement each of the steps
exactly just like geometrically robust
and you can actually classically exploit
that by just computing matrix
Exponential's dirtylee like rather than
computing the full matrix exponentially
you do a Taylor expansion and you cut it
off after owner only logarithmic in many
terms and it turns out that this is like
a dirty solution but it's good enough to
drive the algorithm and if you do that
you can compute your matrix
Exponential's quicker and you actually
get suddenly something that looks a bit
impressive on the classical side already
like with this trick the run time is
approximately N squared times the
sparsity of the problem but the caveat
is that we only solve the feasibility
problem up to some certain accuracy but
this actually improved about the best
general existing algorithm which had a
dimension scaling of 2 to 2.5 but
because we only solve it approximate you
have to be a bit careful about the
approximation errors and it turns out
that for generic instances of what ends
instances the error scaling in this
theorem is better but when you have very
very sparse problems then the existing
algorithm
has a better accuracy and one thing that
I have to point out and it makes me very
very sad is max cut the most important
problem of this kind unfortunately it
doesn't fall into this speed-up category
because our algorithm still requires
this time but max cut is based on a
graph laplacian matrix and this is very
rich structure and so you can just
specify this is also something the
amsterdam gang pointed out but in
principle if you want to solve max cut
approximately you can just directly
specify and then use matrix
multiplicative weights and this turns
out to actually be superior to what we
have here such is life that's okay and
now very very quickly the classical
bottleneck is compute these matrix
Exponential's even if you want to do it
dirtylee it's still expensive and it
shouldn't come as a surprise that a
quantum device could potentially speed
that up because we are really looking
for keep States and so the idea is never
compute the matrix exponentially
explicitly have a quantum computer
prepared but then you have to do some
sampling in order to estimate your
feasibility constraints but the extra
cost of sampling is overtaken by the
cost savings by doing doing this on a
quantum computer and by this we actually
get even better
theoretical run times this is the
classic at the quantum boost that I
mentioned and this problem actually is
the first quantum speed-up at least when
we wrote the paper for these
combinatorial SDP relaxations and it
improves our classical improvement which
improved the best existing results at
least for certain problem instances an
important design feature that made this
possible is that the Hamiltonian is
designed to be very structured so I
think this should also help if you want
to get better better classical
algorithms for computing matrix
Exponential's but it also drives the
quantum speed-up and with that I'm done
we kind of adapted mirror descent to
address the problem of SDP relaxations
of binary quadratic optimization
problems and this allowed us to improve
runtimes for
these problems in theory and again the
main insight we had is to bundle convex
constraints together into seemingly more
complicated single constraints convex
constraints and then use the mirror
descent for a framework that only the
requires primal problems to get
something that is actually competitive
and yeah there's a lot of possible
future directions and we already saw
kind of in follow-up work that this meta
algorithm can be adapted to other
interesting convex optimization problems
like state tomography thanks
[Applause]
couple of previous slides no no just the
one before the last one yes yes yeah
thank you this is a very good point it's
embarrassing
actually in all three but it gets
progressively worse I think like our
classical runtime with the heck of the
Taylor series has a 1 over epsilon to
the 6 and then we became so embarrassed
that for the quantum runtime I think we
didn't track it properly but it might be
1 over 16 over 16 so yeah there's still
a lot of room for improvement and we are
aware of that but thanks important
caveat
of course in the classical setting if
you look at the exports out yes so
they're the the mineral descent is
equivalent to multiplicative waves yes
so here something by moving to the
mirrorless and then you don't get any
algorithm for money just agreed I think
maybe maybe I wasn't precise enough I
think
matrix multiplicative weights fails if
you really consider this problem as an
SDP within different linear constraints
this is the challenging part we actually
didn't do the full analysis for what
matrix multiplicative weights would do
with the general constraint what kind of
we just simply went to the general
constraint and it was very important to
kind of get the accuracy in trace
distance there and then a mirror descent
was putting out
maybe I have a question do you have some
indication that this is somehow sort of
what is optimal for these problems I
don't know them by hard right now to
linear or something that is a very good
question I actually haven't thought
about that your location and the
classical approximation case you're
trying to your truncation is the
resulting error scales I think like with
I think we have to include a polynomial
scaling in the number of total steps
that we incur to get epsilon accuracy so
this is partly responsible for the large
epsilon that we get but this was also
like just a naive hack I'm sure there's
like smarter techniques to approximate
matrix Exponential's more efficiently
but certainly part of the bad scaling
and the accuracy comes from this step
I just wanted to I was wondering like
how do you get the square to the spar
see is it something else chameleon
situation yes it's the low result from
2019 I will call that 20 yes okay
[Applause]